ne
[Müzik]
duyduysan
Evet Sevgili dostlar Hepinize selam Uzun
zaman oldu böyle kalabalık bir gruba
ders anlatmalı çok heyecanlıyım bu
yüzden Kusura bakmayın ve bir soru ile
başlamak istiyorum sunuma O da Bu
salonda kimin 3 milyar doları var
bu birinin Vardır dedim ki koku Gönlüm
vardır mutlaka
bu e beni evlatlık alabilir
şöyle Arkadaşlar ben bir beyin
doktoruyum ve nöroloji uzmanlığının V
yılında okuduğum bir makaleyle şunu
öğrendim
insan beyni Eğer bir bilgisayar olsaydı
kuantum işlemcili bir bilgisayara
benzeyecek Tea ve Ortalama
bir değeri 3 milyar dolar civarında
olacaktı o yüzden soruyu tekrar
soruyorum ve bu sefer hepinizden bir
cevap bekliyorum Bu salonda kimin 3
milyar doları var
bu ara Konuşmamız bitmişti görüşürüz ya
3 milyar dolarımız var ama bir de
biliyorsunuz ülkemizin beyinle ilgili
muhteşem bir sloganı var beyin bedava
Yani demek ki ciddi anlamda bir şeyi
yanlış anlamışız Arkadaşlar ben mesaj
çok yanlış anlamışım beynim bedava
olduğu bir ülkede niye nöroloji uzmanı
oluyorsun ki yani bedava olan bir şeyin
bozulmasının bir değeri olabilir mi
da olmaz yani Türkiye'de Olman gereken
Doktor Euro loji Kadın Doğum ve ikisinin
kombosu olan çocuk doktoru olmak
ama Sevgili dostlar
var Ancak değerini kaybettiğiniz zaman
ne kadar muhteşem bir makineye sahip
olduğunuzu biliyorsunuz
eşsiz bir makine çok değerli bugün
dünyada birkaç bilgisayar var böyle
özellikle yapay zeka ile ilgili
çalışmaların yapıldığı onları Saymaz
sanız
dünyada Geriye kalan bütün
bilgisayarları birleştir Seniz bizi ki
kulağınıza arasındaki Galaxy kadar
muhteşem bir bilgisayar etmiyor
Evet şimdi gelelim
bu makinenin muhteşemliği ne
ne aynı anda Muazzam işler yapabilen bir
bilgisayar mesela gerçeklik algısı şu an
beni burada görüyor olmanız beyniniz
tarafından üretilen bir şey o yüzden
beyninizi ufacık bir pıhtı atarsa Şu an
tecrübe ettiğiniz gerçeklik zemininden
sarılabilir
zamanın akıp gidiyor olma hissi Beynimiz
tarafından işlenir O yüzden cuma gününün
son dersinin son dakikalarının geçmesi
saatler süren var Eğer zaman dışarıda
akıp giden bir şey olsaydı senin sıkılıp
eğlenmene göre farklı hissetmez din bunu
da beynin tarafından üretilen bir şey
düşünce hareket konuşma
karakter kişilik
Duygu
kararlılığımız
tercihlerimiz hepsi Beynimiz tarafından
üretilen bilişsel kognitif
özelliklerimiz
var Bunlardan Tabii kabul ederseniz en
önemlilerinden birisi Ne plan yapabilme
yeteneğimiz mesela yürümek arkadaşlar
kontrollü bir düşme dir bunu planlarız
çocukken Bunu bir kez öğrendikten sonra
da artık ben burada konuşurken otomatik
pilotta bunu rahatlıkla
çok büyük bir kaza çıkmazsa yapabilirim
çok dikkat ettiyseniz planlama
yapabilmek Az önce saydığım bütün
bilişsel fonksiyonların
ve bileşimi ile yapabileceğiniz birşey
bir kere zamanı ileriye doğru sonra
bilmeniz lazım
Bugün dolar kaç olacak acaba
yürü kendi mekanda
iyi bir plan yapabilmem lazım Yani
aslında plan yapabilme yeteneğimiz
beynimizin en pahalı işlevlerinden
birisi diyebiliriz
ve bu sayede emeklilik fonu diye bir şey
uy durabilirsiniz bir kurgu Tıpkı
firmalar gibi Tıpkı sınırlar gibi insan
kurgusu ve belki de 30 yıl sonrası için
günlük Kazancınız dan bir yere ya bir
şeyler koyarsınız bakın zamanı ileriye
doğru sardım mekanda onu içeride
tasarladım kendime koyduğum bir yer var
Kendime çizdiğim bir standart var ve
10'a girebilmek için bir plan yapıyorum
şu mevli Lig ve yine bir plan
Bu konuşmanın kendisi bir plan
arkadaşlar Ben şu an bu konuşmayı
yaparken Ben her söylediğim kelimeyi o
an tasarlayacak olsaydın zihninde o
zaman konuşamadım Gördüğünüz üzere
Aslında insanı insan yapan ve belki de
diğer türlerden ciddi anlamda
farklılaştıran en önemli özelliğimiz en
güçlü silahımız dan birisi
plan yapabilme yeteneğimiz
Bu ancak kolun Hanım bize öğrettiği gibi
Bu plan yapabiliyor olmak tek başına bir
marifet ya da
artık kazandırmıyor olabilir bize
yaptığınız en muhteşem plan
değişmek zorunda bozulmak zorunda
kalabilir boşanma gibi
ne bir gebelik ölü doğumla
sonuçlanabilir
Ya ben burada da istediğim kelimeleri
istediğim sırayla
söyleyebilirim
gördüğünüz e zihnimizin en güçlü
özelliği
kainatı mızın iki tane olmazsa olmaz
temel yasasıyla çelişir
birincisi entropik He Her Şey bozulup
Gider bakın güneşin tükendiği bir yerde
sen plan yapsan ne yazar
Bu ikincisi ise arkadaşlar zamanın akıp
gidiyor olması yani ölüm gerçeği
Bu kaotik bir evrene bu iki yasayı
koyduğunuz zaman Plan yapabilme
yeteneğimiz onun zıddı sayılabilecek bir
güçle sürekli olarak sınanır o da işler
planladığımız gibi gitmez
ya o yüzden az önce şu özelliğimiz in
yanına bir özellik daha koymamız lazım
Yoksa bu özellik arkadaşlar hayatta
kalmanız a hiç bir avantaj sağlamaz
Hatta büyük bir ihtimalle hayatta
kalmanızı engel olur Mesela ben
programın başında yepyeni bir hayata
adım atmıştım
planımı Her şeyimi ona göre
tasarlamıştım çok ciddi bir karar vermem
gerekiyordu O karar verdim kendimce bir
plan yaptım ve dedim ki Timur bundan
sonra hayatına böyle devam edersin
Daha sonra bir anda Corona patladı
Ama sanırım bu odadaki herkes
planlarını nin mikroskopta gözükecek
minicik bir varlıkla ne kadar çok
sığınabileceğin i çok ciddi anlamda
iliklerine kadar tecrübe etmiştir
ne demek ki arkadaşlar Evet plan
yapabilmek bize bir avantaj sağlar Ama
tek bir şartla bu planları yeri
geldiğinde
değiştirebiliyor Sak
esnete biliyorsak Aksi takdirde
Düşünsenize Savaş planı yapıyorsunuz e
Karşı taraftan gelen Ordu sizin yüz
kattınız büyüklüğünde yani planı
değiştirmemiz lazım
Bu plan değiştirmemiz lazım Beklenmeyen
bir çocuk bir hamilelik haberi planı
değiştirmemiz lazım bir anda tanı
aldığınız bir multipl Skleroz planı
değiştirmemiz lazım Gördüğünüz üzere
plan yapma yeteneğimiz
kendisinin zıttı bir özellikle ancak bir
arada olursa işe yarar Plan yapmak
statukocu bir zihnin kaotik bir evrene
dik duruşu iken bunu değiştirebilmekte
Eyvallah demeye denk geliyor Arkadaşlar
bunun ikisini aynı anda yapabilirseniz
yapılan sayısız çalışma psikolojik
esneklik ile birlikte daha sağlıklı daha
mutlu ve daha başarılı olduğunuzu
kanıtlıyor ve Demek ki arkadaşlar Plan
yapmak güzel bir şey ama
değiştirebiliyor Sam şimdi değişmez
kelimesi de bir nöroloji uzmanına
Evet aynen şu anlama gelir arkadaşlar
nöroplasti site yani Beynimiz zaten Yapı
itibariyle sürekli olarak değişir en
büyük özelliği bu plastik kelime siratin
CD şekli değişen demek homosafiens
Yüzyıl önce Nihayet ta simyacılardan
beri hayalini kurdu katıya istediği
şekli verebilme yeteneğini elde edince o
maddeye plastik için vermiş yoksa
günümüzdeki modern yeni ismi ile alakası
yok plastik değişen demek E ben nöroloji
uzmanıyım nöron ör olsaydınız
biyopolitika nöroiktisat nörofelsefe
nuru kelimesine gördüğünüzde sinir
hücresi demek şu an Sizler beni dinliyor
iken
ki beyniniz değişiyor Ben konuşurken
beynim değişiyor arkadaşlar
Beynimiz değiştiği için bir yabancı dili
bilmiyorken bilebilir hale gelirsiniz
Beynimiz değiştiği için yürüyemiyor iken
yürür hale geliriz Beynimiz değiştiği
için bazı konular hakkındaki
fikirlerimizi
değiştirebiliriz Beynimiz değiştiği için
önceden yaptığımız plan beklemediğimiz
Bir Hain likle evrenin bir müdahalesi
ile sınandığı ndan planımızı
değiştirebiliriz O yüzden aslında sinir
bilimi perspektifinden
Ben doğru plan yapabilme ve planlarımızı
da yeri geldiğinde değiştirebilme
yeteneği
beynimizin nöroplasti Sitesi ile doğru
orantılıdır ne kadar esnek bir beyniniz
varsa psikoloji o kadar esnek olur
planlarınızı o kadar esnek olur nokta
logosu arkadaşlar sebep-sonuç logos
Beynimiz ne kadar esnekse
planlarımız da o kadar esnek olur ve o
zaman şimdi
sinir bilimi Aslında pek de kendi alanı
değilmiş gibi gözüken
insan planlarını nasıl değiştirir
konusunda
Evrensel hepiniz için geçerli olan insan
beyni olan herkes için geçerli olan üç
tane temel büyük yasa sunar arkadaşlar
bize bunları ne kadar kullanırsanız
psikolojiniz de o kadar esmer plan yapma
yeteneğiniz o kadar artar beklenmedik
bir durumla karşılaştığınız zaman
planınızı değiştirebilme ve Şansımız da
o kadar artar arkadaşlar
ve Bu bağlamda Zen budizmi ne küçük laf
atmak istiyorum ben bu olan felsefeyle
çok ilgileniyorum
inanılmaz tutarlılıkla var arkadaşlar
inanılmaz yani Sokrates'in epikür'ün
seni kanın felsefesi Sanki o zamanlarda
bir beyin amacı varmış da beyni
görüntüleyebilir görüntüleyebilme işler
cesine tutarlı
vende de şöyle bir söz var arkadaşlar
güzel bir söz en güçlü silahın zihnin
indir ve bakım Bunu söyleyen savaşçı
günümüzde halen daha en keskin en hafif
ve en dayanıklı kılıcı kullanıyor
olmasına rağmen bu sözü söylüyor en
güçlü silahın zihnin dir ama şimdi bu
sözü Az önce anlattıklarından dolayı
biraz at değil etmemiz lazım Evet en
güçlü silahın zihnin dir ama yeri
geldiğinde kılıcı çekiç yapabiliyorsan
Kalkan yapabiliyor bu aksi takdirde
statik Oo bu kainatta her zaman için
kaybetmeye mahkumdur
Evet şimdi bir ilkemiz arkadaşlar Tekrar
ilkesi logo Onun için koydum hepinize
tanıdık geliyordu sosyal medyadan
yapılan sayısız çalışma gösteriyor ki
beyninizin esnekliğini kullanmak ve
bundan faydalanmak istiyorsanız
tekrar tekrar deneyecek siniz arkadaşlar
konuşmayı nasıl öğrendik tekrar tekrar
deneyerek yürümeyi nasıl öğrendik tekrar
tekrar deneyerek
ve bu prensesi Yok sayarsanız ya ben
plan yaparım ben zaten ilk seferinde en
güzel planı yaparım o kenarda Dursun
beyninizin en önemli özelliği ne
bu karşınıza alıyorsunuz demektir tekrar
tekrar demeyeceksiniz ilişkinizde kavga
ediyorsunuz sevdiğiniz insanlar ve
Barışmak mı istiyorsunuz tekrar tekrar
dinleyeceksiniz
davranışlarınızı değiştirmek mi
istiyorsunuz
tekrar tekrar deneyecek siniz İşte bu
kadar basit bunu yok saymak biyolojiyi
yok saymaktır yani ben bacakların
üzerinde değil dirseklerin üzerinde
Yürüyeceğim demekle hiç bir farkı yoktur
Bunu baştan bileceğiz Baştan kabul
edeceğiz tekrar tekrar denemek zorunda
olduğumuzu bize nasıl avantajlar verir
bir kere mükemmelliyetçi bir şekilde
başlamayan larımız var ya bizim hani şu
spora bir türlü başlamayanlar kayıt olup
ve onların başlamasını altında yatan en
büyük Sebep ne
başarısızlık korkusu tamamlayacağım
kokusu Hele bir de mükemmeliyetçi bir
bebeğin tarafından yetiştirildi iseniz
Geçmiş olsun arkadaşlar Hadi bakalım bu
ülkemizde diyor ki
bu yapamayabilirim
ilk düşebilirim
yanlış konuşabilirim
tartışa bilirim baş aramaya bilirim
Önemli olan benim bunu tekrar tekrar
dönemem O yüzden sinir biliminin size
ilkk 3 milyar doları güzel kullanmak
istiyorsanız sinir biliminin plan ve
planları değiştirmeye dair size ilk
Öğüdü Lütfen bunu tekrar tekrar deneyin
ve bu bizim doğamızda var bize
uydurdukları bir öykü var insanın
yaratılmışlığı tacı olduğuna dair hata
yapma lüksü nün olmadığına dair
ebeveynlik sistemi buna katkıda
bulunuyor eğitim'
sistemimi hatayı affetmeyen ve yapmamız
gerektiği yemlikli eğitim sistemi Hayır
biyoloji bunu kabul etmiyor Arkadaşlar
sinirbilimi bunu kabul etmiyor bu 3
milyar dolarlık kuantum işlemcili
bilgisayar bu fiyatı elde edebilmek için
tekrar tekrar deneyecek bu Birinci kural
Bu ikinci profil ise Arkadaşlar şu çok
sevdiğiniz bir laf var bu sağ beyin sol
beyin Eril dişil işte kadın beyni erkek
beyni yok işte rasyonel kafa İrrasyonel
kafama sinirbilimi perspektifinden
baktığımız zaman biz bunun böyle
olmadığını gördük Bizler aldığımızda
matematik ve dili birbirinden ayırmayı
çok seviyoruz O kadar çok seviyoruz ki
bunu işlendiği okullara farklı isim
Koyduk Biz
hangisinin bilim diyor ki hayır bir
matematiğin bir dili olduğu gibi dilinde
bir matematiği vardır duyguyu düşünceden
davranışı inançtan ayıramazsınız beyin
paralel çalışır
o zaten böyle olmasaydı eğer beyin seri
bir şekilde bağlanmış olsaydı Doğan
ağacının lambaları gibi o zaman ilk
sinir üzerinizi kaybettiğinizde
öldürdünüz Noel ağacının lambalarından
birisi patlayınca diğer bütün lambalar
söner beyin paralel çalışır adamın
beynin yarısı yok şu anda o da insanlara
emer çektirmiş olanlarınız varsa belki
de doğuştan yarısı yok ama bunu
haberinde bile değil Çünkü beyin paralel
çalışır O yüzden bir yabancı dil
öğrenmek istiyorsanız sadece gramerini
öğrenmeniz yetmez paralelliği
kullanmıyorsunuz okuyabiliyor olmanız
lazım konuşabiliyor olmanız lazım
konuşulanı anlayabiliyor olmanız lazım
ve yazabiliyor olmamız lazım bunların
hepsini aynı anda yaparsanız esas dili
daha çabuk öğrenirsiniz Aksi takdirde
Yes dizisi pencil Yani 12 yıl haftada
olay saatten boşa gidilmiş verimsiz ne
olmuş deli icad eden beyin edilen
öğretemiyorum Sen de sıfırdan bir dil
edilebilecek kadar muhteşem bir
bilgisayar ara niye paralellik ilkesini
kullanıyoruz O yüzden dikkat eksikliği
olan çocuk da siz Özdeğer
yatırım yaparsanız çocuğun dikkati
toparlanır ha bir dikkat ve Değer ne
alaka taralel çalışır O yüzden bir
insanın davranışının altında
duygusu yatar Çünkü paralel çalışır
planı nasıl oturacağız bunu arkadaşlar
Eğer hayatınızda iş hayatında daha esnek
planlara sahip olmak istiyorsanız O
zaman belki de özel hayatınızda da plan
yapabilme yeteneğinize yatırım yapmanız
lazım orada yaptığınız yatırım iş
hayatında da size iyi gelecek Sen daha
tabağına kurduğun ilişkiyi
toparlayamıyor San yatak odasındaki
ilişkiyi Nasıl toparlayacak sın
bu paralellik ilkesi O yüzden arkadaşlar
hayatınızın önemli önemsiz hiç fark
etmez bütün alanlarında plan yapabilme
ön görebilme yeri geldiğinde değişiklik
yapmayı çalışın Çünkü o size Sözde çok
küçük gelen plan değişiklikleri
78. ayakkabınızı alacağınız zaman bir
hayır diyin
göreceksiniz orada yaptığınız sinaps
belki de üç yıl sonra işinizle ilgili
önemli bir planı değiştirmekte size
yardımcı olacak Çünkü beyin
paralel çalışır arkadaşlar bize Bunun
zıttı Öğrettiler zıttı nedir Yani
beğenmezse matematikçi öteki değil c
böyle Beynimiz için böyle bir şey yok
arkadaşlar
düşünceyi duygudan duyguyu Davranıştan
farkındalığı inançtan gerçekliği
zamandan algıyı dikkatten kesin
Duvarlarla ayıramazsınız
O yüzden Bunlardan bir tanesine bir
sorunun ortaya çıkması Diğerlerinin
hepsini de
da Bozar öfke dürtü kontrol bozukluğu
unda olduğu gibi üçüncü kuralımız ise
Arkadaşlar bu mozaiklik ilkesi Bir de
beynimizin şöyle bir özelliği var Biz
genellikle Mesa plan yapabiliyorum plan
yapamıyorum ben iyi bir insanım kötü bir
insanım işte politikaları iyi yapıyorlar
politikaları kötü yapıyorlar erkek
dediğin şöyle olur Kadın dediğin böyle
olur gibi
zihninizin bir tuzağına düşüp hakikati
bölmeyi çok seviyoruz hangi yapılan yine
sayısız çalışma gösteriyor ki arkadaşlar
beynimizde kesin siyah ve beyaz alanlar
yok
Bu plan yapabilme ve değiştirme
yeteneğiniz ya tamamen yaptığınız ya da
hiç yapamadığınız bir şey değildir Hatta
Siz bu olaya böyle baktığınız takdirde
plan yapabilme yeteneğini baltaladı ınız
sayısız çalışmayla kanıtlanmıştır ben
plan yapabiliyorum diyen adam zaten hiç
yatırım yapması kendine ben yapamıyorum
diyen de yapamıyorum der o yüzden
sinirbilimi 3 milyar dolarlık makineyi
doğru kullanmak istiyorsak hepimize
şöyle bir öğütte bulunuyor lütfen
hedefleriniz arzularınız planlarınız
yapabildiklerimiz yapamadıklarını za1 Ya
Hep Ya Hiç penceresinden bakmayın iki
sizlere
kaybedersiniz fixman set bu çok büyük
bir Kuran'dır
da tam tersini siyah beyaz değil gri bir
skala ile bakın fizik mi yapmak
istiyorsunuz benim çok iyi bir fiziğin
var ya da çok kötü bir fiziğin var demek
Sizi motive etmeyecektir 3 milyar
dolarlık bilgisayarı boşa
kullanıyorsunuz arkadaşlar benim amacım
bir öncekine göre daha iyi bir fizik
yapmak
ve ekonomik durumlar parasal durumları
kitap okuma kitap okuma Hangimiz bir
kitap otu Bir keresinde bitirebilecek ki
böyle düşünürsen hiç başlamasın
o lütfen Sevgili dostlar Sizden ricam
beynimizin gerçek anlamda gücünü
gösterebilmesi için mozaik ilkesini
uyumamız lazım sekiz Mart Dünya Kadınlar
gününde ben kendi Beynimdeki kadınsı
örüntüye de Kadınlar Günü için teşekkür
ettim yapılan sayısız çalışma saf bir
erkek beyni ve saf bir kadın beyni diye
bir şeyin olmadığını gösterdi bize
hepimizde bütün özelliklerin bir mozai
var
12 burcun 12 özelliğini de insan taşır O
yüzden hangi burcu söylerseniz tutar
zaten bunu 4500 yıl önce çözmüşler tutar
bilgi yeteneğiniz bir yabancı dili
Konuşup konuşmadığını da siz Ben
İngilizce biliyorum Dediğiniz zaman
bildiğiniz Siz kendinize kitle dediniz
daha ne ders göreceksiniz ki
biliyorsunuz zaten
var ya da bilmiyorum demek yok Bir sürü
kelime biliyorsun ben sen ve ben sen
günlerin yani o yüzden lütfen bir
skalada göre iyi bir alanda
değerlendirin planlarınızı en muhteşem
plan diye bir şey yoktur Ya da en
korkunç filan diye Önemli olan
planlarınızı bir skalanın üstüne oturtup
bu skalada Gerekirse bir basamak daha
beyaza ya da bir basamak daha siyaha
geçebilmek bunu yapabildiğiniz takdirde
arkadaşlar Ben sinir bilim adına size
söz veriyorum bilimde verdiğimiz sözler
tutar böyle Türkler kovan olmaz gibi
sallanıyoruz
ben size söz veriyorum tekrar ilkesi
paralellik ilkesi ve mozaik ilkesi bu üç
ilkine kadar çok hayatınızda
canlandırabilirsiniz en değerli
sermayeniz işi en verimli şekilde
kullanmaya başlamışsınız demektir
Evet şimdi
Alo şimdi konuşmamın sonunda da Sizden
bir isteğim olacak arkadaşlar Çünkü
ekranda gördüğünüz kasan rayla
çok aynı yerde hissediyorum kendime
bundan Dört yıl önce diğer tedex Kale
için yaptığımız zaman sosyal medyanın
tehlikesi bakımından hepinizi çok ciddi
anlamda uyarmıştım daha henüz da netflix
soşıl dinamita belgeselini yapmadığı
için çok da ciddiye alınmamıştı ben ama
Gördüğünüz üzere Söylediğimiz her şey
çatır çatır geldi logos sebep-sonuç
Evet şimdi kazanmıyor Ben tuğlalı
Apollon tapınağı'nın başı Ailesi
turnuvalar Truva Atını içeri alırken
diyor ki oğlum yapmayın bak bu Hediye
falan değil bir tuzak diyor ve hiç kimse
kasandra yı ciddiye almıyor sonra
kazandığının diğer bütün rahibelerle
birlikte şehir yanarken toplu tecavüze
uğramak için kendilerini Ateş
yaptıklarına dair yazıtlar var
şimdi ben gene size bir kazandırdık
yapayım biraz
ve bu beynimizi düzenli kullanabilme
plan yapabilme ve kauçuk bir evrende
olmanın
bende yarattığı değişik bir projeksiyon
var
o Eskiden yüzde on civarı gözüken Ey
diye içtiği dikkat eksikliği ve
hiperaktivite bozukluğunun günümüzde
okula giden çocuklarda ki oranının yüzde
50 olduğunu söyleyen çalışmalar var
o ilk defa Dünya Sağlık Örgütü'nün
raporlarına göre yanlış ve fazla
beslenen insanların ölümü
beslenemeyen insanların ölümünden daha
fazla
bu post modernizm İnsan zihni için
zararlıdır eğitim sisteminin kendisi
insanın zihin sağlığı için bir
tehlikedir
ekonomik sistemin kendisi insanın zihin
sağlığı için bir tehlikedir
80 yaşına kadar yaşadığınız takdirde bu
odadaki 2 insandan birinin ölmeden önce
de mans olacağı bunu icana dair
çalışmalar var
Ama anlaşılan
Geldiğimiz noktada bırakın 3 milyar
dolarlık bilgisayar larımızı
geliştirmeyi zihin sağlığımızı korumak
daha çok ciddi anlamda da zorlanıyoruz
o benim öngörüm e göre bu saçmalığa
devam ettiğiniz takdirde
türümüzün bu toplu nevrozdan kurtulma
ihtimali son derece düşük ama bir
kurtulma ihtimalimiz de varsa Sevgili
dostlar o da 3 milyar dolarlık
bilgisayar larımızı temel yasalarına
uygun bir şekilde kullanmak beni
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim